-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well,
and now, if you don't mind,
we're gonna get to the news.
The Biden administration
has reportedly warned
that it will ban TikTok
if its Chinese parent company
doesn't sell the app.
Don't mess with this man.
He has no use
for your addictive apps.
Biden's the kind of guy
who can make it through
a whole two-week vacation
with nothing but a deck of cards
and a print edition
of "Sports Illustrated."
"You know what we're gonna do
during dinner tonight?
We're actually gonna talk
to each other! That's what!"
Treasury Secretary Janet Yellen
testified today
before the
Senate Finance Committee
and said the country's banking
system remains sound.
Specifically this sound.
[ Tires screech ]
[ Crash, glass shatters ]
[ Laughter ]
The new CEO
of Silicon Valley Bank
held a meeting yesterday
with venture capital
and start-up clients and said,
"There is no safer place
in the U.S. banking system
to put your deposits."
Plus, if you go now,
the lines are super-short!
[ Laughter ]
The Pentagon today
released footage
of a Russian jet forcing down
a U.S. surveillance drone.
Apparently what happened was
they both tried to take off
from LaGuardia at the same time.
[ Laughter ]
U.N. officials
recently discovered
during a routine inspection
that around 2.5 tons of uranium
have gone missing in Libya,
which explains why
Libya's beaches have experienced
a 600% increase in Godzillas.
[ Laughter ]
A zoo in Michigan
recently announced the birth
of a critically endangered
bongo calf,
which apparently is an animal
and not a medical condition
suffered by Matthew McConaughey.
[ Laughter ]
[as McConaughey]
"I got it real bad.
I got it real bad."
The American Kennel Club
announced yesterday
that the French Bulldog
has surpassed
the Labrador Retriever
as the most popular dog breed.
So you know what that means
for you Lab owners.
-He was my dog. I'll do it.
[ Laughter ]
-So, our writer, Mike Scollins,
submitted that joke.
And, look,
we didn't have to do it.
[ Laughter ]
You know,
I'm the host of the show.
I could have just said
we're not doing it,
but I wanted to do it
because I'm trying to teach him
a lesson and --
[ Laughter ]
There's no -- The undergirding
logic of that makes no sense.
That -- That implies
that everybody
who's had a less-popular dog
until today
had to put their dogs down.
It doesn't -- Just 'cause the --
[ Sighs ]
The important thing is,
you know,
it's the start of the show,
you want to kick it off,
you want to get a good vibe
in the room,
and we showed a clip
from "Old Yeller," so...
[ Laughter ]
And, finally,
longtime Green bay Packers
quarterback Aaron Rodgers
said yesterday that it is
his intention to play next
season for the New York Jets.
It's a perfect fit
because every week the Jets
go out there intending
to play football.
And that -- that's what's
waitin' for you here, buddy.
That was a monologue.
We've got a fantastic show
for you tonight.